we are the Gay & Lesbian Alliance
Against Defamation we do the media
advocacy and anti-defamation work that
we believe moves to changing hearts and
minds about the LGBT community on our
path for full equality in this country
so media advocacy dealing with people in
the media making sure they have fair
accurate and inclusive representation of
the LGBT community in their stories in
their portrayal is whether it's
television film news stories whatever it
may be and then we're the voice against
the defamation that the community still
faces on a regular basis you just you
know it doesn't take long to count off
the times that we've been very publicly
defamed by high-profile individuals from
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff to you know Jerry Lewis on his
telethon last year so there's a lot of
times when we have to step in and say
you're over the line you're wrong you
need to apologize for that that's not
acceptable commentary and and we think
you need to apologize to not just the
LGBT community but everyone for that
kind of commentary and language we talk
with people from all walks of life but
certainly people who are in positions of
high-profile stature and really whatever
world they may be in but certainly in
the entertainment world more so now in
communities of religion and faith we
started a whole program for outreach to
media in communities of religion and
faith and in this very week just
released some information we're working
with Dignity USA and the out people
within the catholic faith who are going
to be very vocal when the Pope comes and
visits the United States very soon
they're going to be very vocal about the
way the Pope thinks and treats and talks
about the LGBT community and and our
role is to help their voice get as much
visibility as it can when the Pope is
here we want LGBT stories to be covered
with his visit as well
well I was had left office in July of
2004 was doing some consulting and
working with real estate development
projects in Las Vegas and in Arizona and
got a call one day from the search firm
and they said there's this job open at
the Gay and Lesbian Alliance Against
Defamation and I had heard about glad
but was not real real familiar with it
and I said yeah that's probably not
something for me but let me give you
some names of some people around the
community nationwide that I know who
might be good for a job like that
because all I really knew about GLAAD
was their work in the entertainment
industry great parties with great
celebrities it'd be fun to go but really
didn't know the extent to which the
GLAAD is an advocacy organization
working in a wide range of activity not
just entertainment at all and so I gave
them some names and they called back a
few weeks later and said well we've
talked to some people and they they
really said we should talk to you about
this role and I said well I'll be happy
to talk with you but I'm kind of doing
some other things I really don't think
it's something that's going to pan out
and well here we are almost three years
later so it did pan out and I find it a
great honor it's really engaging work to
be on the forefront of the LGBT movement
doing the media advocacy doing the
anti-defamation work which is really for
me the cultural change part of the
advocacy work for the LGBT movement is
is the most important I spent time in
the political world so I understand that
part and I understand the importance of
the legal work but the cultural change
in my view is what allows the legal work
to proceed and allows us to build the
political support we need
you